this country is in desperate need of
control you want to take away my rides
neither of you know as much about gun
violence as you think you do I first
spoke to Adam Conover host of Adam ruins
everything in 2015 shortly after his
myth-busting show migrated from college
humors online channel to truTV's cable
channel it's a gateway traffic yeah
educators have been saying that for
years
but it's not true since then a lot has
changed a new media landscape some might
say a new reality so I wanted to talk to
Conover who's about to go on a live tour
and launch the new season about what
it's like to make a show that seeks to
uncover hidden truths in what some have
called the post truth era thank you so
much for having me as really great to be
back and talk to you well we should
mention at the top that I'm actually
married to the casting director of your
show so take that for whatever it's
worth dear viewers she does great work
independently of how well this interview
go so it's fine her her job is not on
the line I can say you're non-biased
last time we talked it was 2015 yeah the
world is a different place now we've got
a different president obviously and it
just everything feels a little bit
different and especially in terms of
getting to the truth which is what your
show is about I feel like I'm constantly
just having to wade through BS to get to
the truth of any story so how has that
changed how you approach what you do it
Adam ruins everything if at all and do
you agree with that characterization I
agree that characterization it's
definitely a different world in terms of
you know the information ecosystem of
beyond everything else I mean I I think
that when we're looking back at this
time period in 50 or a hundred years you
know the rise of social media as a
information distribution tool is going
to very obviously be the most disruptive
and I mean that in the good and bad
sense most of the bad sense for the
purpose of this conversation like
changed possible right
that like the ways of you know
transmitting information the ways people
get information are so out there and
difficult to understand and and you know
we're only really grasping now what the
shift has meant right and that no time
more obviously than from this time span
we're talking about 2015 to now but it
hasn't changed the way that we make our
show or what we think that our show can
do you know people still have a deep
down desire to learn to find out the
truth
people don't like [ __ ] they want to
find out the real story if you present
them clearly and respectfully with here
are the facts as best we know them here
are my sources I did my research I'm
speaking to you with intelligence and
respect as sort of intellectual equals
here people still love that they still
want that and they will still pick that
information or at least there's a large
number of people who will take that
information more seriously than you know
[ __ ] that pops up on on Facebook or
whatever I guess what has happened is
I've a little bit let go of the idea
that we can reach absolutely everybody
that's still our goal it has always been
my goal I used to believe it was a
little bit more possible to get to a
hundred percent of the audience taking
in our message and you know
understanding it and having it change
their perspective I still shoot for that
but now I feel like it's a little bit
more we approach it asymptotically is
that the word like you reach a limit
past which it's like alright maybe I'm
not gonna get that last 5% because they
are really in a you know a whirlpool of
bad information and you know certain
people who you know the into the
informational world they live in is is
so the you know distorted that it's very
hard to get through but I'm always
trying to learn how to do that and try
to be more effective as a communicator
in that way yeah and I think anyone
who's in the business of trying to
communicate ideas which we are has kind
of run up against that and had that
realization yeah in the past few years
and one of the episodes that you
that kind of speaks to that is you had
the character Emily ruin an episode
madam rooms everything which was a
really interesting episode for many
reasons but one of them was he talked
about something called the backfire
effect yeah
your entire show's built around the idea
that if you present someone with better
information you can change their mind
but the surprising truth is disproving a
misconception can actually strengthen a
person's belief in that misconception
it's called the backfire effect by the
way like all effects in psychology
there's debate about how strong it is to
what degree it exists how producible it
is etc right and I've heard people say
oh hey a follow-up study showed such and
such a result didn't show up but apart
from that it's a very very the
phenomenon clearly occurs and it's
helpful when you're thinking about how
to be you know an effective communicator
so the backfire effect isn't effect by
which when you give someone information
that contradicts their beliefs no matter
how factual it is no matter how you know
say hey I've got my sources all right
here look at the data it will actually
increase their confidence in their prior
belief right basically if you attack
someone's beliefs they get their
defenses up that's the simple version of
it and there's a lot of different
reasons why it happens one of them is
that I think is the strongest is
identity protective cognition which is
sort of a related effect that's part of
under the umbrella of the backfire
effect as far as far as I understand it
I'm a dilettante about all these
subjects so I give you my dumb dumb
version right but I'm the guy who knows
a little bit about a lot of things
that's why I do this TV show but the
identity protective cognition is that
when you have built your identity on a
particular set of facts right say you
are a climate change denying author
right you have written books on this
topic you are invited to speak to events
on this topic you have friends in this
community right your literal not just
psychological but social identity is
built on this fact right so the cost for
you on a personal level if you were to
back off of that is enormous right you
would lose all that work you would Lou
all those friends imagine if Sean
Hannity right decided tomorrow he's you
know what I actually don't think Trump
is the greatest guy right like I imagine
how personally devastating that would be
for him right so as a result because of
that those incredible stakes you end up
coming up with different
rationalizations for your old belief
right you're you're when you're
presented with that contradictory
evidence you immediately marshal every
fact at your disposal to wall off that
you know that that initial belief and
protect it because it's so core to you
and the thing is smart people are
actually better at this because they
have more information that they can pull
from right they have more facts off the
top of their heads right yeah yeah I
mean you see these big debates between
you know creationist and a scientist and
the creationist will sometimes win the
debate just because they're so steeped
in that and these are people that can
just marshal they've memorized all the
kind of propaganda yeah and it's a good
point about you know when you hear this
was a really interesting idea that was
presented to me was that when someone
says so much hey why don't you debate me
debate me on this I want you to debate
me right that's a little bit of a trap
right because we want to think that
debate is this like rational perfect way
of you know figuring out who's right and
who's wrong right but the fact is
ideologues are you know they have better
scripts right you know I mean they have
it really it's a thick groove in their
minds right so they can go back to this
the perfect example is cults right if
you go to a Scientologist if you walk
into the Scientology Center you're never
gonna win a debate with anyone in that
building you're not going to be able to
go in and say I can prove Scientology
isn't really you it can't be done right
the reason that can't be done is because
all of the stuff they're gonna throw
back at you is what worked on them right
they were all given like they had a
debate with someone when they win and
they lost that's why they're in the
Scientology Center now right and so
that's sort of like why won't you to
bait me on this that's why it's a trap
right because they have they know all
the things they're gonna feel really
good in the moment all the facts that
you don't have the immediate answer to
right going back to the backfire effect
quickly we had a professor on who wrote
a little pamphlet called the debunkers
handbook which I suggest your audience
goes and looks up online because it's a
really wonderful little couple pages on
how to get over the backfire effect and
he came on our show and explained how to
get over the backfire effect the most
effective techniques and the interesting
thing was they were actually all things
we already do on our show and that I had
sort of stumbled into as a comedian
without realizing right so one of them
for instance is you can't just give
someone facts that show why they're
wrong you have to when someone has an
incorrect belief there's often a
narrative around it right why those
climate change
you know those people pushing it they're
just bought off by so-and-so it's a
conspiracy by these people right there's
a story in their minds and so what you
need to do is you need to replace the
bad story with a good story right the
narrative is very very powerful and
that's what our show is built on right
when we say hey you have this idea that
the diamond engagement to go back to our
oldest segment the diamond engagement
ring is this age-old tradition that's
the story you know the actual story is
that the De Beers diamond cartel came up
with it in the 30s to sell more diamonds
that's both true and a more interesting
story a more memorable and so it sticks
in your mind more effectively and I mean
that feels very much like the euro were
in is this era of dueling stories
dueling narratives and we see it in a
way in the reactions to your show
because if you go on YouTube you'll see
hundreds maybe thousands of response
videos to Adam ruins everything
today on infertility TV we are going to
address a recently released video from
comedian Adam Conover classic
fashionable daring dude actually all
these frames are exactly the same
actually we just seen all the glasses
and each pair was completely different
from the last do you ever watch any of
them are there any that have changed
your mind what do you think of that
entire phenomenon that's a really good
question and a really complex one um you
know I do watch them
I don't watch all of them and I don't
watch of all of every single one of the
ones that I watch you know it's a little
a little painful to watch them you know
it's the ego hits you know it's like oh
oh this person's mad at me Oh see I was
you know our show is very
well-intentioned
my character on the show is
you know like like taking people down
you know but like our show is really
trying to get as many people on board to
try to share the interesting knowledge
that we have with people and when we are
trying to debunk an idea our goal is
always to you know widen the
possibilities for people right say hey
you don't have to be held back by this
idea you can go do anything in the world
right or hey if we change our behavior
this way we'll be more effective in the
world it's very positive right and these
responses are was so negative you know
Adam ruins everything [ __ ] he's
lying to you you know he's he's biased
and all these ways I do look for the
videos that are made a little bit more
even-keeled right and you know I do
really try to pay attention to when I
think we have actually gotten things
incorrectly and in that same episode you
mentioned Emily ruins that underlies
everything we we did a segment where we
corrected our mistakes and we have an
upcoming episode this year coming out in
2019 that'll be similar we really try to
look at the counter arguments that our
segments are getting and try to address
those online so for instance we got a
lot of response videos to our segment on
electric cars but this last episode on
Tesla well let's just say his arguments
were weak in this league the process of
manufacturing a car the embodied
emissions in that car are often greater
than the emissions that the engine would
produce right or at least they're a huge
factor of it right right and so if
you're the type of person who buys a new
car every three years that is far more
important than the engine that's in your
car right now there's obviously
gradations that if you're going from
like a clunker old pickup truck to a
Tesla that's a big change right but if
you're going from a Prius from like a
you know a late-model Prius to a to a
Tesla right then you're actually
increasing your carbon footprint what
you should really do is drive the Prius
into the ground because the Prius is
pretty efficient or any other hybrid and
then buy a used Tesla right that is as
or more impactful of a choice than just
saying like hey sign me up for Ilan's
like electric dream machine right you
attacked the Elan fan club which yes
kind of notoriously notorious the
notoriously defense and that's a huge
example of identity protective cognition
because Ilan oh my gosh this guy is the
best
speaking of narrative this guy builds
that built the best narrative for
himself ever right he says I am the man
of science I'm the man of action I can
do the thing that no one else can do
right I a failure is good wonderful
thing that he that he promotes the idea
that failure is good and if you buy my
product you can be like me right it's as
a result like people build their
identities around this you know and so I
had videos made by I mean these were
folks saying that I was biased against
Tesla and they were making videos where
they're literally wearing Tesla like
jackets and they've got a test they've
got Tesla memorabilia up in there
filming studio and underneath the video
it says click here because they have an
affiliate link where if you sign up to
buy a model 3 they'll get you know a
little go get a little kickback and you
know that doesn't mean their arguments
are wrong but like that's where they're
coming from right at the same time we
got enough responses to that segment
that I concluded look everything we said
in the segment was true but I felt that
we didn't present it with enough nuance
right then our that my ruin of it was a
little bit presented as a slam dunk I
don't buy the electric car you know when
really it's like yeah you know more like
I like buying an electric car is a more
nuanced equivocal thing when it comes to
green stuff and the real message is use
what you can as long as you have but if
you buy an electric car you know when
your old car breaks down if you buy a
used one they that's pretty good we say
all those things but you know it was
just the I felt that you know people had
taken the wrong message and maybe I bore
some responsibility for that so we so we
spoke to that in our in in the episode
Emily ruins Adam ruins everything at the
same time you know some of the response
videos they have no idea how to respond
to you know we did a video on why alpha
males don't exist in humans what up
freaks names alpha Adam I'm confident
straight up banging and if you think
women don't love me I'm gonna debunk the
F out of that myth no not like that guy
at all being a rude [ __ ] doesn't
make you an alpha male sure some alphas
are I'm not denying that but this is
just a gross mischaracterization it's
almost like they don't know what real
alphas are like it's just an
unscientific idea it's not part of
biology sociology anthropology
it just does it doesn't exist it exists
in some animals we talk about how it
doesn't exist in wolf that's a myth and
has an interesting story behind it but
like yeah there's no there's no person
who researches humans on the planet who
would tell you there's such a thing as
an alpha male right it's a complete suit
of science and so we did a video on that
and that got the most negative response
we've ever gotten right we've got so
many videos of people calling me a beta
male kook [ __ ] like that you know and I
don't know how to respond to that that
is the most identical yeah that's just
name-calling and I mean making your
response video calling someone a beta
cuck is really the most alpha thing that
yeah but there's an older episode where
you have a dr. oz like character we're
doing kind of a show within the show
thing here today see look there's my
camera there's your camera see my camera
your camera your camera is on my camera
okay so meta you're critiquing the way
that nutrition advice is dispensed but
really the the bigger critique seems to
be the way expertise is presented in the
media what do you think the major
problems are with the way that expertise
is presented these days in media there's
a lot of experts who the reason they're
experts on television is they're very
good at being on television you know and
that doesn't mean that they don't know
what they're talking about right but
like hey why is neil degrasse tyson like
the only astrophysicist do you know you
see on television well hey he's great on
television you know but that does limit
our you know the range of perspectives
that we that we get and you know some of
those people are better being on
television than they are at being
scientists so one of the things that we
try to do on our show that I really
pride us on is that you know we don't
bring people on the show because they
have a book to promote we have them on
the show because they are actually the
subject matter expert and in many cases
they're the expert who we're basing our
segment on you know this is the
historian who wrote the book on X this
is the journalist who broke the story on
Y right this is the person who you know
was covered in the article that we read
that it you know really knows the thing
and
man I love talking to those people and I
love bringing them on television because
like a lot of them you know would not go
on TV otherwise right we had this guy
offer our immigration episode who for
episode on the wall and why the border
wall you know why why building a literal
border wall would be counterproductive
it's counterintuitive but building a
wall wouldn't stop people from coming in
it would actually stop them from going
back in fact the whole idea of building
a border wall is misguided the Mexican
economy is doing quite well right now
and population growth has slowed way
down so there's not much pressure to
immigrate our expert we had on that was
a researcher who has gone down to the
border every year for I believe since
the 70s and just done field research on
how many people are crossing the border
he goes around with a notebook and he
interviews people you know he is doing
straight up field research how many
people are crossing the border and he
has a data set that is massive and that
he told me the government uses his data
set right and so he came on our show and
he told us hey the level of border
crossings currently is the lowest it's
ever been or the lowest it's been in
decades right this is the [ __ ]
who knows you don't normally see that
guy on TV guess what cuz he's not you
know he's not great in the CNN for
heads-up display right no in those
contexts it seems like the requirement
is you have a strong opinion about
something and you can see data in a you
know sound byte yes yeah exactly but we
have the people on who have actually
seen the work on the ground I think one
of the best things our show is able to
do is when we can boost the signal of
folks like that who are doing who are
actually uncovering the knowledge right
but whose message wouldn't normally be
heard by you know the average comedy
viewing audience right there's another
older episode where you're kind of in a
coffee shop with this anti-technology
hipster the Internet's destroying
society sorry
I should tweet that no you shouldn't and
no it isn't well oh god they're
multiplying
you kind of take him back through this
litany of complaints going all the way
back to Socrates complaining about the
written word yeah which is I really
appreciate it and I love it but I do
wonder you do come through that YouTube
ecosystem college the show start on
college humor on YouTube and then
migrated to cable so you're very
familiar with that that world I would
say it is undeniable I think that media
does change your perception the kind of
media you're taking in so how do you
think as someone who's kind of steeped
in that world how do you think this more
fractured media environment is changing
people's perception of reality I guess
that's a really good question I think
it's changing it quite a lot and I think
it's very hard for us to even understand
currently the scope of how much it's
changing yeah you know that segment that
was our episode Adam ruins the internet
and that was strangely one of the
episodes that I think has become out of
date the quickest because that idea of
everyone complains about their
cellphones but I say at the end look
this is the great this is a great
communication tool people are connecting
with each other in ways they couldn't
before how is that anything other than
than a massive social good I say at the
end well I think we're starting to see
ways in which it's not right I mean at
the very least that's Facebook's ethos
right Facebook I say hey we connect
people that's an unequivocal good right
connecting that's important that's
basically charity you should all you
should all be thanking me Mark
Zuckerberg for connecting everybody
right and now we kind of know hold on a
second collect connecting people
willy-nilly like in this sort of random
huge way is like oh my god that is
having some unintended consequences
right like I use like oh my god it's so
amazing that people with common
interests can find each other but hey
there's certain people with common
interest to when they find each other
that makes them able to form cults and
terrorist sex so that's a terrorist
sexts no terrorist sex I didn't want to
get a terrorist Sexton yeah some thing I
thought a lot about lately is that we've
gone from
you know one too many too many too many
right in terms of our broadcast it used
to be that we had you know NBC ABC CBS
and then later cable and then we all
received right and then the Internet the
great promise is anyone can talk to
anyone oh my gosh incredible the
gatekeepers are gone right oh great
tear down the gates let's all be free
I think we're realizing that the some of
the things the gatekeepers were doing
was good right yeah that like there are
certain ideas that you want a person in
a position of expertise to be able to
tell you with authority this is not true
okay or you know if you just look at you
know people say people start saying
couple years ago they say hey where did
all the where did all the KKK and Nazi
guys come from they're back right
well actually what happened was they
were always there right you know that
they were small minority they're always
there but the thing was they weren't
allowed on TV they were only allowed to
go on you know Jerry Springer where
everyone yell and throw fruit at them
Yeah right yeah with the Internet
holy crap now they can broadcast like
everybody else and so their voices have
risen in a way now I don't think that
means that we shouldn't we should just
stifle those communication tools by by
any means right but it's an unintended
consequence of that ethos of more
connection is always better that we're
grappling with and that we don't yet
know how to handle like I'm starting to
crave holy crap I think I want a little
more but not gatekeeping but I want
those authority figures curation
curation I want curation you know I want
I want that security of someone who
knows more than me
telling me and telling other people in
it in a big way one example of that and
you you appeared on Bill Maher show and
talked about this a little bit the it
was right on the heels of Alex Jones the
conspiracy theorist getting kicked off
of just about every platform yep and you
seem to be saying that it was a problem
because for instance YouTube was making
money off of his lies
I don't like Alex Jones but Alex Jones
gets to speak everybody gets to speak
this is not the Internet of 1996 where
you put up a website and you know
using like the public pipes like these
companies Facebook YouTube Twitter these
are the majority of time Americans spent
on the Internet right we're talking
these for the air this is ABC CBS NBC
right and they're making money off of
him they're running ads against him so
is so you know I agree with you about
free speech and that's of concern to me
as well I also don't think those
companies should be profiting off of
what he's saying I don't advocate for
particular people to be deep platformed
or for them to not have platforms I do
find the thing of like hey aren't we
supposed to have free speech I find that
to be a false argument if I'm going to
be a distraction right because we all
know that that's not what the First
Amendment is about right what I want in
a more broad sense is I want these
companies to take some amount of
responsibility for what they are doing
to the information ecosystem and to all
of us right so it's not just that
YouTube was making money off of him
it's that what he was doing was like an
integral part of YouTube's business
model on every level
you know like YouTube created an
ecosystem that he thrived in and then
profit off of it profited off of it in
every possible way
so it's not just that they were selling
ads on it right it was that their
algorithm was drawing more people to it
right and it's that they created a
honeypot for bad actors like that to go
into right so the whole all these
internet companies are based on and and
I used to have this point of view too
it's very late 90s early 2000s point of
view about the Internet right that like
hey we're just the platform you can't
get mad at the platform right you can't
get mad at Google because you can get to
a bit torrent file from it right that
was remember that was an ethos we all
had I can't sue don't sue Napster come
on they're not the ones sharing it right
that was a way that I felt when I was a
young internet revolutionary right the
platform isn't a spa isn't at fault now
I realize that the way that these
platforms are built the choices that are
made by the
people who make the platform they're not
neutral you know it's not just an open
Commons that people are wandering into
they're the architects of this space
they're the ones who are creating here's
how the content is shared here's the
kind of content that's allowed here's
the content that does well here's the
content that we promote here's here's
how you can make money on the platform
right those are all choices that they
make and so they bear a responsibility
for what happens on the site period
these sites are the biggest sites
possible I mean you know people watch a
billion hours of YouTube a day I believe
and 70% of those views come from
YouTube's recommendation algorithm right
the bigness of them is partially what's
concerning to me is you you know and
with this alex jones debacle
it was the coordinated crackdown on him
that was a little bit concerning to me I
was like YouTube Spotify Apple they all
acted it once and then Twitter kicked
him off after Jack went in front of
Congress and it seems like there's all
this weird pressure coming from places
that we're not even sure exactly where
the pressures coming from does that
concern you at all that side of the
equation because he's kind of like on
the front lines and like he goes then
what's gonna happen next does that move
you at all
yeah I mean it does it's not the best
situation for you know Tim Cook to have
the final word I mean my guess is look
Tim Cook is like a very he seems like a
very like ethically driven guy in a lot
of ways you know and it really seemed
like it was like three people at Apple
going like you know what we can't be
having this right and getting rid of it
and for that to happen for that a small
number of people to have that much power
yeah that's worrisome I'd say it's about
as worrisome as you know it was a couple
decades ago when we just had three
broadcast networks at the same time I
don't think that worry should get in the
way of us having a more holistic
conversation about the role that these
companies need to play these platforms
are enabling bad information to travel
lightning-quick all around the world
right and it's their algorithms that are
doing it right so somebody needs to step
up and I would hope that we would do it
in a socially coming together sort of
way where we can have a conversation
about what is that you know what are the
standards that we want to have as a
society for information and how are we
gonna do our best to push conspiracy
theorists to the fringes where they
belong
you've got a live tour coming up called
mind parasites and from what I gather it
seems like some of it might relate a bit
to what we've been talking about don't
you just give us kind of the broad
strokes of what is this live tour well
so this is a brand new format for me a
couple years ago I did and Adam ruins
everything election special which was
all about the 2016 election election
history common misconceptions this is me
this is just Adam Conover on tour it's
not an immense everything on tour and
it's me trying to find a new way to
combine stand-up and information into
sort of a live comedy event it is a sort
of a synthesis of a lot of the topics
we've been talking about today with kind
of like a psychedelic biology class I
talked about these really wild creatures
in the natural world that are parasites
that control the minds of their hosts
and get them to do what the parasite
wants which is some of the most
fascinating biology there's there's like
literally thousands of species that do
this and some of them are really really
strange they literally zombify you know
insects and other creatures and I use
that as a way to talk about the forces
in our lives the cultural parasites that
are trying to control our behavior for
their benefit because my show is kind of
based on the idea that and I think that
the name of your website is based on the
idea that you know reason can cause us
to improve our behavior right that were
rational animals and that the more that
we know the more perfect our behavior
will be and you know even broader way
our entire society is based on the
assumption that humans are rational
animals that we can't be hacked that we
you know always choose what's best for
us that we weigh the evident that's
what's voting is based on right
choose the person who speaks to me the
most right but what I'm realizing is
that we are eminently hackable right
that you know by social media algorithms
first of all but also by you know
ideologies by ideas by substances right
and I don't want to spoil too much of
the show because I come at it in a
couple different ways but I talk about
different ways in which I realized oh I
thought I was choosing this behavior but
actually my mind was being controlled I
was under the influence of something
that was trying to control my behavior
for its own benefit and I think that
happens a lot more than we give credit
to and I think the first step in
fighting back against it is to
understand that it does happen so that
we can counteract those forces and then
the new season of the show is coming up
now are there any big themes like what
should we be looking for in the new
season I'm very proud because we tackle
topics that in the past we wouldn't have
thought we would be able to do so our
season premiere this year is called Adam
ruins guns which is a topic that I used
to say you know you can ask my writers
from our first two years I used to say
we will never do that topic because as
soon as I tell you hey I'm gonna do Adam
ruins guns almost everybody in the
country thinks we'll you better say what
I want you to say you better say my side
if you oh no I'm gonna be ready I'm
marshalling my arguments right now I'm
gonna change the channel rights like
cultural identity sorry yeah yeah people
people armored up right away and and so
you know that's one of the fault lines
in American society and I used to say
now I want to hit him where they don't
expect it I want to go hit the stuff
where you know because we're only that
divided on a small number of issues
right that's like 1% of issues in the
country the other 99% of the issues you
know you can talk to people people
aren't tribal about those issues and you
can get to their you know their heads
and their hearts more effectively right
but guns they're so activated it's so
much harder but we said this year no you
know what we've been doing the show this
is our fourth year we of writing the
show we've gotten really good at it and
we really think that we can make some
progress on this F on this issue so in
this
episode we we have done an episode that
I feel reasonably confident that I can
say that anyone from any ideological
background can watch and be corrected on
things right that there are things that
about guns that they believe that they
are incorrect about that we correct in
an entertaining and hopefully
enlightening way now I expect us to get
a huge amount of response videos and a
hate mail for this segment from
everybody and it's one of those ones
where I just got to be like hey bring it
on you know if if people are if if
people if it's causing their gears to
grind on that issue I think it's a good
thing yeah okay well maybe I'll make one
and please do well Adam thank you very
much for talking to us we're looking
forward to the new season and it was a
pleasure for a reason I'm Zach Weiss
Muller and I'm Adam Conover
[Music]
you